thank you and so good it's good question
huh yeah
okay so our next start is by Maggie
Sottero Toby from USC and he's talking
about another kind of non convex
optimization problems that actually
connect through this weak optimization
as well through the subversion or
maximization of thanks for the
introduction and having me here so you
know at this point I think non convexity
has been well motivated so I don't need
to really talk about it so when dealing
with non convex problems we have sort of
two set of approaches one is based on
convex relaxations and SDP hierarchies
and another but we kind of do know that
these ideas are not always perfect
sometimes they're not very good in terms
of memory even when we have infinite RAM
so but and also sometimes they're not
efficient in terms of data meaning that
sometimes comebacks relaxations for them
to actually work you need more data
samples but then there is sort of more
classical approaches which dates back to
the 1800s which is just following the
gradient and so most of what I'm going
to talk about today is you know what
kind of guarantees can you get when you
just follow the gradient and as a side
note I actually think these two areas
are much more related than one would
think but I'm not going to talk about
this today so I'm going to talk about it
in the context of two problems one is
about learning very shallow not the
nonlinear models like very shallow
neural networks and then this one is the
continuous one and then I'm also going
to talk a little bit about discrete
optimization problems in this context so
in the learning the values in particular
what I'm going to focus is unlearning
values so these are very simple
nonlinear non convex problems and
hopefully the idea is that if we gain
some insights into the convergence
behavior of these nonlinear problems and
also sample complexity maybe it's
extendable to more nonlinear objects so
so it's kind of the model is deep
learning but shallow thinking but kind
of happening anyways so huh
but so we start from zero hidden layers
so this is very simple it's just a
really non-linearity you get to see you
know the dot product of your data if
your weight vector and then you do a
really non-linearity max of 0 and X so
what I want to understand is what
happens if you just use gradient descent
to learn this non-linearity so you sort
of have you know it's sort of a teaching
model you have some W star which obeys
your data or base it's coming from a
planted sort of rail you model and then
you just want to understand what happens
if you minimize the difference and maybe
you like sort of a regularization
function so that it's more generalizable
or more data efficient in some way so
but you can simply do is sort of apply a
projected gradient descent here where
the projection is on to the your
constraint sets and the question one may
ask is what happens if you do this so in
order to sort of understand when this
converges and at what rate and how many
samples or you know observations you
need to converge it's good to compare
this with sort of a well-known baseline
which is if we just wanted to solve the
linear version of this problem meaning
there was no non-linearity here then we
would be doing just a least squares fit
to the data subject your constraints and
then if you actually benefit that I can
actually find the planted solution then
there's very precise phase transitions
for this we understand this problem very
well so above a certain number of
observations you you can precisely find
W star by solving this sort of convex
program so I'm going to use this n 0
quantity which are you haven't really
defined but I've sort of a baseline on
how many observations you need in this
case
so if we go back to the relative model
now so again we don't project a gradient
descent if you assume your input data or
a Gaussian then what you can ensure is
that as long as you're a constant factor
above this phase transition then you you
basically converge at a geometric
to the the planted W star and so in
particular if you know your W star for
example to be like s parts in D
dimensions then this tells you that as
long as the number of observations is
above sort of a constant times s log the
over s then you converge at a geometric
rate to W star and this is starting from
zero by the way so if there's no
sophisticated initialization scheme here
what is kind of interesting about this
result that the fact that this
regularization is convex is irrelevant
so this is all host for any language so
pick your favorite regularizer as long
as you can project onto the sub level
sets then this result result what so or
does not have to become as it is
anything you like as long as you can
project and it's tractable still works
everything is fine I just start from
zero no sophisticated initialization
talk about that if there's time at then
so one is like the input is Gaussian
that that you can really remove that's
not a big deal
like analysis goes through another one
is you know you might even argue like
why do you have a ID data that I also
think eventually you can remove because
you know maybe you can replace sample
complexity with more data dependent
sample complexity that kind of thing
is sasha was talking about in his
tutorial in the bootcamp but I guess the
more serious assumption is here is like
the fact that there is a planted model
you know in signal processing we like to
do this and it's kind of valid but here
is kind of weird to assume there is
at that model and that might require
more work so I'm just putting it out
there
I've been surprising he has not
complained about this yet yeah there is
a planted weight vector right so kind of
weird to assume that but I'm saying like
I'm assuming there is a W store and then
I'm drawing data at random so that is a
little bit yeah there's a unique one
it's a planted model basically but
anyways so I just do also mentioned yeah
so all you're saying is that like a
compressed sensing model do you assume
that is some W star [ __ ] you know the
UW store then you drop the model that
gaussians that random and then that
creates your output right it's not like
you have pair of inputs and outputs and
then you try to find W star
so of course that learning rel uses is
not really difficult because there's a
bunch of water Memphis I can learn no
use because it's whether they're not
about just projecting gradient descent
so so kind of the idea here is we we
just want to understand what happens if
you just learn them via projected
gradient descent but because there are
more monotonic functions there's all
this literature in the statistics
literature on learning single index
models and and more recently there's
also been some work about learning rel
use using kernel methods but the point
is just just understand what happens
that he use gradient descent so that's
kind of the idea let me briefly mention
how this kind of proof works because I
think that's kind of an interesting
connection which is the the various
approved works is it basically connects
the you know characterizing convergence
rates of non convex gradient methods to
supremum of stochastic processes and so
if you can make that connection and
there's a bunch of tools we could
potentially use to do this and so the
idea is very simple but but it actually
works so the idea is if you have your
iteration so WT is like project on to
your constraint set you do one gradient
iteration your loss if you look at this
minus W star so if you kind of look at
the two norm of the error the idea is
that hopefully you want to show that the
two norm of the error goes down at every
iteration so you want to show something
like this one sure this is bounded with
a constant and so if you if you can show
this then then obviously you get
convergence and so what happens here is
that actually you can replace this just
by the fact this is two norm you
essentially write the two norm as
supremum of something so it's kind of
like you write this is a supreme of U
transpose W T plus 1 minus W star over
this
now because because this is actually a
projection onto K what you can do is you
can take the the supreme um only inside
the sort of a cone this cone is
essentially like the tangent cone is
like the conic Hall of K minus W star so
now what happens is what you really have
you have a stochastic process as a
function of U and any general vector in
W so you can really think of this as
you're trying to bounce something like
so freemum of X and WT minus W star and
the supremum is over you inside some
cone and then WT inside some set K so as
long as this quantity is random so you
can use tools from stochastic process is
to try to actually about this it's not
so easy sometimes you have to do generic
training and things of that sort but
essentially that's the idea so you can
learn something about convergence rates
of non convex problems by by bounding
stochastic processes that's kind of the
rough idea and I just because this is I
am looking at a random order I just want
to mention that this it is sometimes
dangerous to just think about random
models so in particular one popular
paradigm these days is that you know
local optima or global this is why you
know gradient descent method converges
and the answer to that is really no
local Optima are not global so this is
not about learning values but a very
closely related model so I just wanted
to put this out as a warning so you have
different local search heuristics all of
them are known to converge to local
optima in this problem and what you see
is that basically all of them converge
to different local Optima so not only
are there a lot of local optima they're
actually sometimes very close to each
other so it's very this is basically
about learning absolute value
nonlinearities sort of gets me to the
motivation of for the second part which
is ok maybe we don't want to assume
random models but can be there
you know if you assume all things state
the data is deterministic can we show
some sort of approximation guarantees
for for gradient descent right and I'm
going to do that in a context of a
different problem so so we're not going
to try to assume any randomized
assumptions but instead of showing
convergence to global Optima will show
convergence something with high quality
in some sense and so they'll do that in
the context of sub modular maximization
so and if this part is joint work with
how much has any at UPenn and I mean
Carabosse the idea and just another
acknowledgement you know all of these
results were done on the boards of
Simon's from last semester so this this
problem is about that function
maximization so this is a discrete
problem in nature but you see you can
transform it into a continuous problem
so essentially the idea is you have a
bunch of items you want to pick a subset
of these items that are in some sense
most informative so what you have sort
of is a ground set you have sort of a
scoring function that assigns a value to
each subset and then you want to
maximize overall subsets that maximize
the scoring function so that that's kind
of the idea
so submodular functions are a particular
class which are characterized by sort of
this diminishing return property in the
sense that if a is a subset of B and you
add a single item to it then the value
you get out of adding this item to it is
bigger than the value get out of out of
adding this to B so if you kind of add
if you have a very food already adding
like a black bear it might not be very
better than if you don't have berries
right so that's kind of the idea and
just the contemporary things of interest
is sort of in big data summarization so
if you want to pick a subset which are
more informative in some way you can
cast a lot of these programs that's so
much as so modular optimization and I
think something that maybe not a lot of
people have looked at yet there are a
lot of cool problems in optical design
where if you want to you know pick
informative measurements am i among a
particular class there
you can also use some modular ideas
there but this is not something that I
think you have been looked at this but
you know so it's also very useful in
computational imaging when you want to
sort of design your modern imaging
systems so I think there's been a lot of
talks on this already but let me just do
a quick recap of what is known so that
you may be like re sauce fit better into
by that context so one part is a sub sub
modular problems that a lot of people
have looked at it sort of monotonic
functions which is if a is a subset of B
then F of a is less than F of B and so
I'm put in particular one is sometimes
interested in sort of maximizing
monotonic functions with a cardinality
constraints so you're in addition you
want to not only pick a informative
subset but you sort of have a maximum
number of elements that you want to pick
so in this context there is sort of a
famous PD algorithm which is a very
simple algorithm essentially you start
from zero you add one that the most
informative item and so on and you
repeat and so there is very good
approximation guarantees for this
algorithm in fact you get one one minus
one over Y approximation ratio and it's
also known that you cannot do better but
you know outside of monotone for
functions essentially the greedy
algorithm there's many famous examples
that it doesn't work so well so you
often you know for general problems like
matrix and so on there was a lot of
sweet talks on this in the last workshop
this doesn't work well so what people
often do is they go to the continuous
domain so essentially one studies
continuous relaxations of this called
sort of the multi linear extension and
the idea is that you you sample each
entry according to probability X I and
then you take average with respect to
this random subset sampling and so
essentially what you're looking at
you're looking at the discrete problem
of memberships which is like a zero one
vector a sort of a continuous vector X
right so so that's
this is there's a lot of averaging here
but this way you sort of transform the
problem into a continuous problem and
what is known is that if you can solve
this it actually the optimal solution is
a discrete point and so if you can solve
this and you can solve the original
problem so one can try to solve this
instead so there's a lot of interesting
algorithms on how to solve this is the
one particular one is sort of the
continuous PD method which gets very
good approximation ratios so this you
can for the continuous people in the
audience you can think of this as sort
of a variant of Frank wolf essentially
but it's a very smart variant that is
designed for this particular case and
again under various assumptions there's
a lot of approximation guarantees for
this and this is really very nice
literature on this
so in particular in the monotonic case
this is also known to get 1 1 minus 1
over e approximation issue but you know
I'm going to use the start from one of
the speakers in the last workshop where
one issue with this maybe is that you
need you know you never know this ik
continuous function f so because it's an
average of a bunch of things so in
practice you don't really have access to
it but you can basically sample and
basically get a empirical average and
you have to use that and one issue with
sort of these continuous methods and in
general what could happen is that you
might not even have access to the
original function itself in the sense
that it might be already an average of a
bunch of functions so you might might
already have sort of a stochastic
setting where the number of you know sub
functions fi could be very large so so
in any case you even you might not even
have access to the discrete function let
alone like the continuous version and
this happens in a lot of like so various
data summarization or influence
maximization problems this this happens
that a lot there and then you know if
you also do the continuous relaxation
then there's an another sample
complexity issue so the point is that
you would like to have algorithms that
can be stochastic right and
and in this setting so if you try to do
this the Frank wolf kind of algorithms
it's not very amiable to being
stochastic and I'll mention why so when
I saw this continuous extension actually
in the tutorial from the last program I
got curious what happens if you general
just run gradient descent on this
continuous extension right so you know
and this is one of the questions I asked
from one of my friends which ended up
being the core is what have you tried
gradient descent and so what I mean by
that is you want to maximize some
continuous function that's just too a
projected gradient descent so in the
case of cardinality constraint problem
you do get gradient ascent and then you
project onto these cardinality so
basically you project on to proportions
of the simplex essentially and as I said
this could have the added benefit that
if you're kind of in a stochastic
setting then we know that projected
gradient methods are very easily you can
develop stochastic variants whereas like
the continuous greedy methods it seems
that you know you can actually cook up
examples where the stochastic variant
fails and we have one such example in
the paper and essentially the idea is
that averages and maximization don't go
well together right and so if you have
sort of an empirical average or a sample
like a stochastic version of the
gradient then the Frank wolf kind of
algorithms may pick may easily fail
whereas you know for projected gradient
methods is very easy you just have a
stochastic sample you just run yeah
stochastic gradient descent so let me
tell you about some theory that you have
for these problems but this is very
limited so it only applies to a very
limited class of problems but hopefully
we can extend it so the the theory we
have is for the most general case of
continuous or modular optimization
problems which are called
weakly D or sub-module essentially these
are all problems where the gradient of f
of X is bigger than some gamma gradient
of a boy
when X's entry way smaller than Y so the
particular case of gamma equals 1 is
sort of the continuous extension of a
normal sub sub modular problems so gamma
equals 1 is what you would get if you
extended discrete some modular problem
and a particular focus as I said is on
really stochastic problems for us so the
first kind of a simple result is that
all stationary points have a very good
not very good quality but have actually
some good quality so this is what I mean
by stationary points is sort of
equivalent of gradient equal to 0 for
when you have constraints so if if the
function is monotone and gamma weakly
sub modular then what you can show is
that all stationary points have a half
third of this approximation property so
in the case of gamma equals one this
becomes one half so it's not 1 minus 1
over E but but it's something like it's
at least something and of course you
know that if you pick a very small step
size then then you can also perhaps
converge there eventually it's not clear
at what rate but you know that you can
converge so the I do like to point out
that this can be viewed as a very simple
extension of resource that is known in
the literature in particular for the
experts in the audience the case that
it's gamma equals 1 this is sort of an
immediate consequence of this demo that
it often appears in a continuous PD
literature so just wanted to point this
out so but are are really that they are
focus is not really just studying the
quality but it's how can you get there
and and they can you do this in a
stochastic manner so first of all let me
talk briefly about the approximation and
guarantee here which is 1/2 the bad news
is that there are counter examples that
basically there are examples that show
that you cannot do better than 1/2 so if
if you want to start from everywhere you
can actually construct local Maxima that
have approximation ratio of 1/2 but if
you start from other points in
particular 0 but we've observed that the
it
variable in practice and we have not
seen any instance that it gets worse
approximation ratio compared to greedy
or continuous PD methods we have some
ideas how you might be able to prove
these things but yeah you know not very
concrete ones yet but again our point
our focus is really on developing
stochastic variance and so this is kind
of what what we can show is if you do
projector stochastic gradient methods in
a sense that if you have access to a
stochastic Oracle which is unbiased and
has a certain variance then if you do
stochastic gradient methods project the
gradient methods that then that has good
approximation properties and so the
running time is surprisingly similar to
what you would get out of a convex
optimization problem so you have like
one over epsilon and then you have like
Sigma square over it sounds good yes for
any convex constraint so this is rbj I
don't know it's convex then yeah and
there's also mirror descent variance of
this which is actually very helpful in
in theory at least so you cannot do
repeat all of this using a mirror
descent scheme and the reason this the
mirror variant is important is because
essentially you can measure smoothness
in a different norm and for example for
cardinality constraints what you would
get for the Lipschitz constant is that
came times the margin of F which is like
the maximum value of a single item and
and so the the running time would be
like K over epsilon and only
logarithmically dependent on a number of
items so if you know some of the
continuous greedy literature usually
this dependence is much much heavier on
the number of items like and for or
something like this so at least in terms
of the number of iterations those
dependences go away here is sort of some
simple numerics
to demonstrate that you know
this is competitive with baselines so
this is a very simple example where you
you only have monotone Khan monotone
score function so this comes from sort
of a recommender engine application
where you essentially want to pick like
the top K informative movies to show to
the user essentially that's kind of the
idea and so that we do various scoring
functions and so really obviously for
because it's monotonic really works very
well but but this this part shows you
that that projected gradient descent
with very few iterations actually can
achieve the same approximately the same
objective value as the greedy algorithm
and this part also shows you that the
sarcastic variance is very much
competitive stochastic variance of
continuous Creedy
in fact continuous PD seems to be
converging to a different local optima
which is worse and this is this also
tells you that the stochastic barriers
in terms of total Oracle calls to this
function f is also competitive with
greedy algorithms another maybe
interesting experiment here is because
especially I'm more from the continuous
side of things and we're kind of used to
solving maxcut problems using that the
SDP approaches but you can also use you
know the this gradient descent on the
multi linear extension and the
interesting part is and some of these
graph problems we actually observe
better approximation ratios if you just
do gradient descent on with continuous
extension so it would be cool to study
what happens within in this particular
cases
I mean these are just the the objective
value there's a max code problem higher
is better so these are like I mean this
is from the old classical paper zipper
you you apply max codes and these are
the objective values you would get out
of them so let me do a quick recap I
think I actually have a lot of time
right all right no so I can't go into
the deeper stuff so let me briefly
mention those so slightly deeper is in
the neural network businesses if you had
one hidden layer right so you have your
input you you have your input to hidden
layer and then you also have an output
there so one hidden layer so the formula
would look something like this and then
you have some non-linearity in the
middle so re sort in this is very
preliminary but this is kind of
deterministic so so there you would want
to put a nonlinear model like this you
want to minimize over both set of
weights and we would like to understand
the properties of this optimization
problem so so far what we've looked at
we have some results for other nonlinear
models but they're not as strong so
let's say a very non realistic quadratic
model for fee of course this is not
realistic but the results are somewhat
insightful so we look at this
optimization problem in the following
context which is we assume the problem
is over parameterize so the input
dimension is d the number of hidden
units is K and the the total number of
samples you have is n so if this problem
is over parameterize in the sense that
the number of observations is less than
a constant times KD so you have actually
more parameters than the number of
observations this is actually the regime
where neural networks are trained
usually and the network has to be void
in the sense that the number of hidden
units is at least twice the dimension of
the the input the
then for this the in this setting and
the cool thing about this is completely
deterministic result what you can show
is that all local optima are global all
saddles are stripped there's the
direction of negative curvature and so
which implies that gradient descent
converges to the global Optima so this
is optimizing over W only we assume like
the way that the last layer based our
Peck completely random so so this is so
far everything I said is deterministic
you always converge to the global Optima
but of course this doesn't tell you that
the quality of that global Optima is
good and for that you do need some sort
of diversity assumptions because if you
just repeat your data set obviously you
cannot fit you know just repetitive data
with very good accuracy so if you assume
some generic assumptions about the input
like they say if the input data is
Gaussian then you can also show that
that error is in fact zero so that
that's kind of the idea and you know we
have some results about more realistic
nonlinear models or this by the way with
other than Jason colleagues at USC I
forgot to mention that and we have some
resources about other nonlinear models
but they're more local in flavor so we
don't have global resource but we do
believe that you know impact is it does
seem to work that - it's like if we do
get zero training error yeah so just
quickly mention some related work in
this space so the for training shallow
neural networks there's a sort of a lot
of recent results so there's kind of two
flavor of results that let me directly
compare this so one is there's a lot of
interesting resource including by people
in the audience where they do look at
over parametrization but it often
requires more over parametrization in
the sense that instead of assuming n is
less than you know at constant times KD
the assumption is usually the number of
data samples is less than the number of
hidden weights but basically hidden
units so it allows it requires more over
parametrization
than us so that that's kind of the main
difference we can get a very very modest
organization right so it's like a
constant factor from the total number of
parameters and there's also you know
there are a bunch of interesting results
in the other regime where you have more
observations than the number of
parameters again this is not exactly the
region where neural nets are trained but
so in this setting there is a lot of
local convergence results where you show
that if you start sort of close to the
global Optima and you just do gradient
descent or an example of gradient
descent then it converges and then so
this is the dis class of problems and
there are many others using other
methods other than gradient descent if
you use tensors or kernels and so on so
there's a lot of interesting work in
that space also so with that let me
conclude quickly so so a quick recap I
talked briefly about learning nonlinear
models including shallow neural networks
and also stochastic approaches to sub
modular maximization and my research
over the past years have been really
following this question of have you
tried gradient descent and so it started
in the context of some imaging problems
and you know now I'm looking at the sort
of more nonlinear problems and so here
are some of the references on sort of
non convex problems that I've been
working on so let me end here for
[Applause]
questions
so the max cut problem you showed is a
non 102 unsub not lab so do you still
have to start at zero or let your
results today hold to the extent for
that case no not yet but eventually
behold so is very limited it's just
focused on monotone and just one of the
UM problems at this point but we hope to
be able to extend it slowly so for the
nice good problem you just didn't you
think we were just curious because okay
because it's different from the normal
paradigm I'm used to wishes we do like
low rank factorization to solve max code
like at least in the continuous
literature so I was curious we were
curious how does it actually work so I
mean the number STP numbers I took from
the papers I have no idea we didn't
drown the SD piece ourselves
any other questions
so this night-night
[Applause]